je suis au poste-frontière de rédéné en
pologne effectivement alors vous le
voyez derrière moi les conditions sont
vraiment difficiles vous voyez un feu
derrière moi il ya des gens qui sont
restés ici qui ont passé qui ont passé
la nuit qui sont là depuis plusieurs
jours alors ça ce sont ceux des
personnes celles des personnes qui ont
réussi à passer la frontière mais pas
seulement il ya aussi leurs proches et
qui sont venus d'autres pays j'ai parlé
tout à l'heure à un ukrainien qui habite
à prague qui est venu ici il ya trois
jours il attend ses parents qui sont
bloqués de l'autre côté ses parents qui
sont partis il ya trois jours également
de kiev et qui depuis depuis la nuit
dernière sont bloqués entre la frontière
ukrainienne et la frontière polonaise
dans une zone tampon de 2 1 km environ
une zone dans laquelle se trouvent des
centaines de personnes alors je vais
vous montrer un petit peu ce qui se
passe autour de moi en ce moment vous
voyez toutes ces voitures et bien ce
sont des gens qui attendent des de leurs
amis leurs familles leurs proches c'est
aussi des gens qui sont venus à pied qui
attendent que les bus qui ont été
organisés par le gouvernement polonais
et bien les récupère et les emmène dans
des centres d'hébergement d'urgence un
énorme élan de solidarité s'est mis en
place ici en ukraine alors il faut
savoir que la communauté ukrainienne ici
ici en pologne pardon il faut savoir que
la communauté ukrainienne en pologne
justement est très forte cela des liens
très forts entre les deux pays puis à la
solidarité donc été atik avec 7 7
ouvertures de centres d'urgence des
écoles dans la région je me trouve
qu'ils ont été réquisitionnés pour
servir de centre d'hébergement d'urgence
puis ensuite les gens sont acheminés
vers les grandes villes la plupart des
gens en fait veulent se rendre dans ces
grandes villes cracovie varsovie
et puis il ya aussi cette question qui
reste c'est que sur la population de 44
millions d'ukrainiens il ya 260 mille
résidents étrangers qui eux aussi
tentent de suivre le conflit hier je
vais parler avec deux ans bien deux
étudiants gens biens ainsi qu'à des
représentants de l'ambassade du
de la zambie qui me disait et bien ce
que c'était très très difficile en tout
cas du côté ukrainien de passer sept
cette frontière donc il ya cette
question est ce que c'est une solidarité
finalement à deux vitesses mais en tout
cas l'effort d'accueil il est il est
bien là et au vu des arrivées là vous
savez de l'autre côté de ces checkpoints
qu'on voit au loin il ya plus de 50
kilomètres de files plus de 50
kilomètres de bouchons sur cette route
donc cet effort humanitaire il va devoir
continuer parce que la situation elle
est très très loin de s'arranger ici à
la frontière